one of my values was you know do what's
right when no one's looking and I think
that's a really important value that you
are doing these things behind the the
scenes um you know because your mind can
play some some some games on you and you
know you can take the shortcuts you can
um you know do things like not do your
recovery and I want to know but you but
that's that's not high performance
that's not you know striving and walking
towards you know your your purpose and
goal so it's just a nice big reminder of
um you know sort of what is what is
excellence and and you'll be rewarded
for that that hard work that you do and
that sacrifice that you do when when no
one's looking you'll be rewarded at some
stage